what do i eat man you know I do IIIi
have a lot of smoothies because I don't
really like to eat that much I get a
little bored over time of eating you
know I work a lot and I'm running around
a lot out here in Los Angeles and so
it's hard to nuts to come back home all
the time because of traffic so you don't
really get that that time to eat all the
time
your home-cooked meals I like small
oranges those little oranges cuties
tangerines tangelos different types what
do I like I like a banana sometimes I
like apples with peanut butter you know
sometimes I get a damn Capri Sun you
know outside of that I like water you
know some I'm gonna have me some ice
cream I'm a little lactose-intolerant so
I'll hang with the sherbet but I like
different types of meats and brisket
some fish I like a flaky fish something
white wahoo
mahi-mahi you know every every now and
then maybe once every two or three weeks
I'll be a little bit of sushi I go heavy
on the wasabi with a lighter soy sauce
that low-sodium if you're still rocking
high sodium soy sauce
dude that's that like I mean that's the
damn oxycodone of Japan right there get
the green top okay
go light sodium now when I'm at home in
Louisiana I have whatever they got you
know what I'm saying I'll let somebody
just stick a dip of catfish in a vat of
mayonnaise and just beat me in the back
of the throat with it because I like to
have them Louisiana snacks I like
different vegetables I'll eat a salad
sometimes with no dressing on it just
plain I like it like that also I don't
need a lot of cheese I like cheese but I
know that if I like it a lot something's
wrong you know cuz then I just eat
cheese you know sometime I just wish I
could just have cookies with cheese on
them but you can't have that it's not
good for you you know I like avocado
when I was young my daddy used to eat
avocados he'd cut them in half take the
pit out fill each half with mayonnaise
and and eat those with a spoon eat it
out of the Rhine and I remember sometime
I'd sneak over there by him and he'd
give me a little mouthful of that Ivo
Mayo and that was a good time reminds me
of being young when it come to desserts
I like coconut cake I like Boston cream
pie like coconut
cream pie I like a creme brulee boy you
could find me in the desert club okay
sugar Buster's is for mother all right
I don't mind a chocolate pudding dude
you know if we got to go cake I usually
like to go a German chocolate I like a
king cake around the holidays that's a
Louisiana tradition and I like that uh
creme brulee and I like that bread
pudding any type of bread pudding I
don't care you got raisins in it dude
I'll be in it and that's what I like I
appreciate good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one